Hey guys, how is it going it's Justine today we are going to  be making something. This is kind of like a two-part video first
We're going to do a taste test
Of the new fireworks oreo, there's no s so, just a single work there's popping candy inside, so that should be
Exciting after the taste test we are going to be making a firework Oreo cake it's a no bake cake
So there will be no baking involved fingers crossed it works out also to go with this dessert I'm so excited about this
Cause baby you're a firework
We're Gonna be integrating
Pop rocks into our dessert today
Will we die today?
You never know shut up Justine
Start cooking prepare the chocolate  according to directions on the box set aside in the fridge
Hmm, okay according to the box [two] cups cold milk beat it beat it. Yeah
I might need these directions five minute pudding direction. That's it
one, two
Pudding will not set if made with soy milk. That's a good note
this is five minute pudding
Why do with the rest of my minute?
All right, you know what I don't know how many minutes that was but it's enough minutes for me
putting in [oh] my favorite part
This is industrial. I could blend a body in here
Is that funny or is that not [um] I'm not sure
I love blending bodys
It's my weekend activity. Has anybody seen Santa Clarita diet because if you haven't watch it
I am drew barrymore. Let's do the taste test now
So this has a little firecrackers in it
I can hear it inside my head. I don't know if you guys can hear it but like inside my head I can hear it.
[mumbling] It taste like an oreo with pop rocks in it
whatever
It's like unexpected and because I swallow some of it
I've been going down my esophagus, and it's crackling and popping this thing is still freaking futuristic that I don't know
I'm just to put this on. We're going to pulse it up
I think this is good enough to be fair
Is this medium? I think this is a medium sized bowl. Actually think this is a large to be fair. Let's melt you up
Well that's boiling gonna mix this into here
This is healthy I love fitness
There's something that I meant to address the beginning of the video is if you're wondering Justine why is your shirt look like it's destroyed
I bought this shirt like this. This is how you know you're a true idiot you buy a t-shirt that looks like it's been absolutely
destroyed. Uh-oh
It's snap crackling and popping because of the butter. [ow] listen I'm putting the microphone close to you
Can you hear it?
It sounds like rice krispies. Look at this workstation. Look how I'm working
This is the most organized cooking
Show not a show you've ever seen now. We need to grease our pan
Cooking spray is my answer to everything. Oh is your door squeaking let me get that for you.
[laughing] Oh no a piece of my expensive ripped shirt
Oh jeez
Give it a nice press
So you just want to line the bottom of your grease pan
With your cookie mixture
There we go that's our base of our cake. So I think I'm gonna try to put some pop rocks in it
Hopefully, they don't pop yet.Cause we're not ready for them
[crackling] Oh yeah, It feels like my teeth are breaking
Nice layer of that
Is my head making that noise or is it my cake
Both
Stirring one cup of cool whip. [alright] Put little extra because I like extra
We're mixing our cream cheese, our sugar and cream until light and fluffy
Alright our cream cheese is going in.
This place is a mess
Oh jeez, oh god
Yep, that's gonna work, right?
Probably should have used the mixer
So I cleaned everything up, and I was so excited with the outcome of my cream
And I realized that I forgot the heavy whipping cream that I needed
I'll follow directions
What's this?
This is for alcohol? Which one do you want [tablespoon], do you think so?
We're going to find out two tibbals two tibbals of heavy cream ah perfect now. Now we know
So now we're going to take this and we're going to press it into our mix that we have cooling in the fridge
What's the head pop rocks in here before we close up shop?
Wow, this is beautiful
It sounds like it's cooking itself can swap this little mixture in here
Okay, well this isn't cooking it's it's just crackling. Oh my God. It's really good. Let's put some more on here
Where's our pudding oh we got our pudding here
Okay, pudding layer done
I want this to be the best fireworks, oreo cake that anyone's ever made
So because I don't want to dirty another pan. I'm just going to mix it in here
We're gonna put a lot in here because this is our topping and this is the first thing that your party that you're going to
See and they're going to be like wow
[ow] How is this dangerous?
So now we're going to add this on as our final little delectable layer
I mean this cake is talking to me. We are having words. It's so loud. I can't believe it. It's gonna be crazy if you actually eat this
Like there should be a disclaimer on it
We're gonna top it off with some more. Oh my gosh there all making noises over here
So I put my delicious mixture in the fridge
to cool
It's still making noise. This is crazy. Snack Saks [laughing]
Grab'em, share'em, zip'em, take'em. You can't [um] that's something that you can make up
I'm going to put a little mini oreos on it a
Little red and the Blue. Do not look good together, but sorry
oh
I'd also like to note that I didn't realize how it's fun to Pop rock words put this in perspective
I would like you to what I'm shooting today
I'm not gonna have time to go down to the candy store and buy pop rocks
So I sent a postman and I get the final bill. It was $80 per freaking Pop Rock I
About lost my mind. [I] mean granted we probably got a
[30-30] pack, but like that's a lot of money
So we're going to make this cake. We're getting our money's worth
Is today the day of all the things that make this kitchen? And this is all I'm going to go out
So here's the good news. I'm not alone
[Nathan] is here and so is Sarah which means we are going to do the same stuff
I mean, they don't have to do things
I'll definitely take one for the team
But I think that this is something [that] you should definitely bring to a picnic especially like you
The fourth of July coming up your friends will love it
Come join the fun. We just need to Kick school
This is a way to go you're right you let your bite
Just put that in your mouth like that. [no], no, I'm serving. Oh look at that. That's actually holding together
Me yeah and see the thing we how many pop rocks are [you're] gonna get
No, I mean the whole top is just yeah, [oh], it's a crunchy. Oh, wow wow. This is something
I'll do the same okay. Yep, all right here. We go one two three
Hmm
[has] a very funny situation hmM?
Out there it has kind of the [laid] [out]. I think that might be a breeze [on] my sweatshirt. I'm sorry
That's definitely a piece of your sweatshirt in my cake. Yeah
Oh, wow. Yeah, I guess more I got your blood sweat tears and shirt into the k yeah
I'm sorry, it's delicious though. It's actually pretty good
It's weird though. It does pop in your throat. Yeah
So so what's this layer underneath club rocks like what cream or something?
Should the bottom layer is the firecracker firework oreos are very lended and then cream cheese cool whip?
With more fireworks pop okay, huh?
I mean, it's just layered with tons until the pop rocks just [a] huge bite of this see what?
Of just the top layer yeah
Wow
Oh my God
[evelyn] burning classic in my mouth like what God look we're in [glasses] with a purpose
And it doesn't stop once you eat it. It's like there's hidden pop rocks and my teeth Mm-hmm
The cake that keeps on taking mmM. Keeps on popping all right fruit. Thank you. Mm-hmm
It's an interesting mixture well. That's it. This is the oreo
Firework cake this is kind of a recipe that I developed in partnership with a [googol] recipe
But it was really was supposed to be a no bake mitt, lasagna cake
But really yeah this [dis] tournament you took complete creative control. I admire that [thank] you
[I] mean it might be you know just a creative direction that I went down like a the wrong way
But it's here. It's actually pretty good though. [ya] [know] [I] actually liked it like I ate half of it. [I] know it's awful
I know you do I feel a sugar coma coming about Mm. Not
Cool. Have a full thanks for watching thanks for shooting. Thanks to her taste testing, and we'll see you [guys] next video
There's anything that you would like to see me bake in the future leave in the comments below and I'll see you later. Oh
This is the diaper